[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum
rosenbaugh whatever you guys like thanks
for tuning in I know uh you got a lot of
choices we talk about this all the time
you got a lot of choices there's a lot
of podcasts a lot of actors with
podcasts but we help people here Ryan we
talk real stuff
get deep yeah damn it yeah we're not
we're not smartless we're smarter
uh we appreciate you guys uh following
us
um subscribing to us on YouTube Apple
Spotify
uh everywhere make sure you follow us on
our handles right
smart fur would have been a funnier
anyway uh inside of you pod on Twitter
inside of your podcast on Instagram and
Facebook that's correct and uh write a
review really helps the show truly helps
the show and if you want to help the
show even more join patreon patreon.com
inside you uh we need your support we
are the little show that could uh so
thank you for all your love and uh yeah
that's about all I have to say I'm doing
the YouTube live today fun at 4 pm for
uh all my patrons and they get to ask me
questions we just chat
it's gonna be a lot of fun also the new
CD is out the album's out sunspin.com
you can get a CD signed it's a new CD
eventually it'll be out in streaming but
if you want to keep saying a cool CD I'm
signed or unsigned we have cool new
shirts for sunspin mugs calendars get
them while they're hot thank you for the
support go to sunspin.com you can also
book the band or uh all that stuff
um
Zoom the band and you could also Cameo
me and for inside of you
stuff yeah go to inside of you what is
it called the inside of you online store
and get tons of merch all right I'm done
talking about that uh broadcast uh as
always I really love my guests Kristen
Bauer yeah she was an open book man uh I
always when I say that I I just get
excited because I know you're going to
relate to a lot of things she talks
about and she's just really open and
gets personal and it was a joy to have I
mean if you're a True Blood fan or not
she's been in some very cool project
some that we talk about and we talk
about our life and all that jazz uh
without further Ado Ryan are you good
I'm good you're well I'm good let's get
into it you wanna get into it let's do
it inside of Kristen Bauer it's my point
of view you're listening to inside of
you with Michael Rosenberg
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience thank God they're orions I know
thank God Ryan does a lot of things
though really yes he he edits he writes
he's taking this awesome class now Ryan
Ryan's doing a lot of stuff he's a
comedian yeah he's an athlete what yeah
you know back in high school he was most
likely to most athletic he was most
athletic out of 88 kids in his school oh
my gosh
there's a lot the 87 others weren't that
athletic so
my school had even less than 88. get out
okay but I just somebody just got here
in Wisconsin yes how many people were at
your high school there were 20 kids I
think 19 in my whole grade I think what
you know the thing that sucks about that
is everybody knows if you're stupid I
had like 400 people so I kind of hid
underneath the so no one really yeah you
know I could just hide through all those
other dumb kids there was no hiding here
are the fabulous things
there were really no clicks because we
didn't have the brainy kids I had to
also be the athletes had to also be The
Artsy kids like we all
we and and there were of course the
super nerds that I cheated off of and
there were of course the athletes which
I I was one too Ryan but I don't think I
was the first out of 88 but
we had no locks on our lockers what yeah
I guess because there's so few he knows
who stole it it's narrowed it down right
oh my gosh no locks in there you know
what the unproverted you know what the
first thing I thought of was uh no I
wonder out of there's not that many
people here and if you've grown up with
them like did anyone hook up no nobody
hooked up at all no one slept with each
other in high school no and that was
that well I well actually I did you did
actually I did with who
Eric
Eric who no you don't Eric what grade
what grade so here's how that would
happen so there were two ways that you
could hook up with people you I already
liked you I thought you was gonna say
here's how it happens that we anyway the
vagina no I can tell you that too I mean
it's fairly you know routine you go to a
party and you drink too much but
the the way that people could date was
when you went from middle school to high
school you you were in uniform up until
eighth grade ninth grade started upper
school we called it and then that was
like fresh meat came in right so we we
were fairly segregated in our lower
middle and upper schools Frank Lloyd
Wright designed the building or his
school did his school did it's a
beautiful school and they were
concentric circles with these really
interesting hallways that would connect
what's concentric mean well who knows
consent next to each other Ryan circles
next to each other I think so adjacent
circles
I don't know Centric Khan is with with
Centrics
yeah okay Ryan if Ryan doesn't know no
one knows no I didn't do well in math oh
I wish that was most athletic I was not
doing that obviously right right I was
athletic and in calculus see that's what
I mean we didn't have enough people
you had to do all of it
the kid who got voted most attractive uh
went to Penn it was a genius so really
yeah he had it all going forward that's
not fair where is he now is he still
doing I think he's like curing diseases
in Brazil I think oh my gosh that's last
I heard of him but yeah so there you go
yeah well we're doing something Ryan
we're helping people with anxiety life
talking about real stuff I guess I know
but we're not saving people well maybe
we are maybe we are maybe we are we
don't know I mean if you think about the
world without because I'm a I am a
really an artist being that's what I do
I do art stuff I do a lot of other stuff
but it drains me so right but the what
would the think of this world
without books music
film TV it's death it's it's concrete as
far as you can see you know what I mean
it's it's
1984. it's it's not livable
well
yeah I don't know how I could survive
without a world without music with a
world without music music is the one
thing there's not many people who could
no that's the one thing books I like
books but I love music there's something
that calms me if I'm in the car and I'm
just yeah I always have calming music I
don't like dance music people playing
hard music I Gotta Christopher Cross
just sailing away the reverie caught up
in the reverie
um anyway but yes I agree with that I
agree but the connection is important
connection connection is really you know
that's I think that's the most important
thing well that's like you know when
they look at the blue zones right where
people live to be over 100 more than
other places there's five what are they
um they're Islands one is Okinawa
there's another one in Italy there's
another one I believe in Greece and
they've looked for what are common
threads and one of them is community
another one is Diet another one is
moving and around your body you know and
and then another one is um I believe and
it might be part of community is valuing
old people
they're part of the world still they
aren't just be they don't like Hollywood
become invisible
rocks lamps you know what I mean as an
actress over 50 I'm becoming just a
[ __ ] lamp you know really that's how
you feel yeah that sucks it does ageism
ageism we need to get rid of ageism it's
a thing so right before I know I know
right before I came here this could be a
skin cancer awareness but I have this
Band-Aid on my cheek because I didn't
even see it on any of these angles you
didn't have to bring it up [ __ ] but it
doesn't matter you can't see it but we
can imagine wait can you swear on you I
should have cleared this with you yes
yes you could swear okay good that's
that's lucky for me
um but I'm sitting there waiting for the
guy to come in
the doctor and I'm looking at this
enormous
billboard thing I guess smaller than a
billboard because it fits in a room but
it's large from my perspective and it's
a white woman with blonde hair
and because we age the worst the fastest
and and it's at the top she's really old
and at the bottom she's young and it has
these
small intervention to stay young a
little more intervention a little more
so at the bottom is like wear sunscreen
and drink water at the top is facelift
and I'm looking at this thing for ever
you know it takes a while to come in
and I'm like wow there is not
it's a the fairest person which is me so
I'm like well that doesn't feel good
right and then also
it's not a dude
right dudes aren't sitting there and
then the big ad below it was a picture
of an ass with cellulite and it was how
do this new injectable drug that you can
get rid of that like wow it is so tough
to be a chick in some ways I absolutely
agree with you it's been like that for I
mean forever ever forever ever and it in
my lifetime it's changed quite a bit in
some ways and in other ways it hasn't
changed at all yeah yeah so there you
have that so anyway back to high school
and Eric no
yeah oh here we go but you said
something about your skin cancer yeah it
was cancer no thank God so my father
died of that my skin cancer we had
melanoma yep how old was he 68
oh my God that's so young it's too young
was that the worst thing in the world
for you were you close with your father
yeah
uh immediately I could see it just hits
my heart when did this happen forever it
happened in 98 and I'm and and since
yeah and I've lost a lot of people since
then my life has definitely been shaped
by loss
but my mom has had it my brother and my
sister and they're all my brother and
sister are older
so every four months since he got it in
96
I go in and strip down and the guy looks
me over and cuts a few things off and
then I get the 10 days later they call
and say you're fine
so that's how I guess you do it I had it
I had skin cancer a year ago you did it
was Squamish oh yeah yeah so it wasn't
no no thank God and no I have to go in
every six months for a checkup yup that
just was in there last week yep and uh
so you know the drill see this is this
is the people that don't have melanin
thing did he did he um your father was
he one that never went to the doctor or
never
he would have went in early they could
have fixed it could have gotten to it
his was
um part of a mystery where it started
inside his body and
they didn't find it on the skin first
my mother that's very rare and then
one of the treatments for it in fact the
only treatment at that time I don't know
now
they would they would take that tumor
and they would make a vaccine from your
own tumor
and inject it back into for I think he
went every week and then it was every
month and then it was every two months
but the hospital that removed the tumor
lost the tumor
and so what yeah so his chance of
survival went from 50 to 5.
with that lost item oh my God yeah
that's freaking brutal it's brutal so he
got a general vaccine at the John Wayne
Clinic here in California and they do it
at the Mayo and John Wayne and you know
it's just they don't really have
anything for it once it's done that
oh you know what's amazing is
I could tell why you're such a great
actress
because when I mentioned your father you
immediately tapped into that emotion
just came over you yeah it was like boom
right there yeah you can easily cry on
stage on second you I can but you know
not if it's crap writing right so like
right so like True Blood I
I love Skarsgard you know I love him
wow emotional again I know so Alex would
say she'll even cry if she talks about
crying
I cry a lot when it's like I I don't
have any filters at all and but you know
when I was doing a billion guest stars
on every procedural
and it's like
my daughter's mother's brother was it
the brother brothers dot baby who got
killed you know I was like I don't know
how you do that for 12 hours a day I did
it but it was just
ARG but when it's great writing you know
like so when I got to the seasons where
we found Pam's more vulnerable side
I I would just look at Alex and think if
I don't if I didn't even see him for a
month I could cry about that
so yeah you had a close relationship
with him I did
and so just hearing his name
yeah immediately yeah but I also cried
when I met your dog you got a little
emotional when you had Blanche you love
dogs I could see it you rescue I love
when people rescue go to arm animal
rescue mission my friend Shiro runs it
Rescue an animal there's so many animals
rescuing yes dogs rescue for God's sake
it's not a purse you don't need a
designer dog what's wrong with people I
don't get it I don't get it you you know
you don't love the thing because it's
purebred you know then that makes you
crazy right so you love the thing
because you love the thing you know
what's weird is
I never
thought I could love something as much
as I love my dog yeah I am obsessed with
her isn't it the best I don't know I I
start to think something's wrong with me
yeah I wake up in the middle of the
night to kiss her I'm not I swear to God
just to hold her and she's like come on
dude it's 3am yeah she's like I'm
sleeping but I I just freaking she barks
she knows yeah hey back it up
is this your first dog uh no my other
dog died two years ago and um that was
that was painful oh it's so bad it's bad
it's like it's so it's family so you're
losing family you're losing a kid I
could tap into that and that feeling
when I had to put him down and it's it's
not easy well I would use my dog dying
when I was on those freaking csis or
whatever they are and I decry I'd be
like literally trying to dredge up that
day
inside of you is brought to you by
Shopify
I am on Shopify all the time folks if
you have a small business or growing a
business or a big business and you don't
have Shopify I don't know what to tell
you because this is the easiest thing to
use and it's the most helpful for
starting your business
um
you know I sell things on my website I I
this is going to be difficult shipping
the handling it's all right there in
front of you
they have everything on the left you can
just go down oh analytics let's see how
this product's doing let's see how this
how this product isn't selling well
maybe I should do a discount easy to set
up a discount you just press a button
how much percentage you want off 15 it's
so easy to use Shopify and now I have so
many items on my inside of you online
store thank you Shopify Shopify makes it
simple to sell to anyone from anywhere
Ryan whether your thing is vintage tees
or recipes for ghee start selling with
Shopify and join the platform
simplifying Commerce for millions of
your favorite businesses worldwide with
Shopify you'll create an online store in
your Vibe discover new customers and
grow the following that keeps them
coming back and thanks to 24 7 support
and free libraries full of educational
content Shopify has got you every step
of the way it's how every minute new
sellers around the world make their
first sale with Shopify and you will too
it's that simple Shopify makes selling
simple so you can put yourself and your
ideas out there whether your thing is
making ebooks or earrings Shopify makes
your success possible
go on try Shopify for free and start
selling everywhere this is possibility
powered by Shopify sign up for a free
trial at shopify.com
inside all lowercase go to shopify.com
inside to start selling online today
shopify.com inside this show is
sponsored by betterhelp therapy online
the amazingly talented people who appear
on my podcast and me let's be honest may
seem like we have it all figured out
but we obviously don't navigating any of
life's challenges can make you feel
unsure whether it's a career change a
new relationship or becoming a parent
unfortunately life doesn't come with a
user manual a trained therapist is the
next best thing therapists are trained
to help you figure out the cause of
challenging emotions and learn
productive coping skills which makes
therapy the closest thing to a guided
tour of the complex engine called you
as the world's largest therapy service
betterhelp has matched 3 million people
with professionally licensed and vetted
therapists available a hundred percent
online plus it's affordable just fill
out a brief questionnaire to match with
a therapist if things aren't clicking
you can easily switch to a new therapist
anytime it couldn't be any simpler no
waiting rooms no traffic no endless
searching for the right therapist learn
more and save 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
inside that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside
yeah I mean you did a lot you you're not
kidding La law Everybody Loves Raymond
Two and a Half Men uh Star Trek CSI
Desperate Housewives Fantasy Island
Boston Legal justify Lewis and Clark all
these shows I hoard around now
was it was it exhausting was did you
like being a guest star were you like I
want to be a regular I want to do I mean
were you ever thinking of quitting oh
God did I think about quitting so I all
of the above because I came into the
industry
kind of just looking for you know I was
an art major in school design right
and then I kind of went into Fine Art
and then I didn't really know what I was
gonna do and then I dropped out my
parents were mad and so then I they
didn't want to support me anymore so I
got a billion media labor jobs so I was
working like five crappy jobs for
minimum wage or less who was minimum
wage back then I remember I was making
335 at one job yeah I was making seven
dollars an hour right so you have a
billion roommates and
you know you're young right so you have
more resiliency really
and and I was craving Adventure so I was
looking for a better job so I went to
make up school
because I was painting portraits and I
thought I could actually paint faces and
then there is that's how I got on sets
and I was like this is really fun
because it was a nice balance to just
you know just I just pictured this life
of being alone in a room
do an art like what do you even do with
that like how do you sell it you know
what I mean so crazy like you go crazy
yeah so which is pretty much what I've
been doing the last two years so
without being on a set saying you're
selling stuff you commission stuff yes I
do it's pretty cool it is pretty cool
and it's feeling more cool now than it
did then then was
just I I didn't know what the f I was
gonna do with my life so and now it's
more of a passion you can do this you've
done you've had success right you keep
working and this is like this is
something I could just do and have fun
that's it that's exactly I had to leave
the Shire you know have Smeagol get the
ring throw it in the thing to get back
to the Shire to go oh it's actually kind
of nice here right right
but I I then ended up
going to an acting class I went to the
Beverly Hills Playhouse so Milton
katsalis is and I was with Jocelyn Jones
it was brilliant and still is and I
remember she called new people down to
the stage and she said what do you want
to do here
and I was like I'm just kind of looking
for a better job than washing windows
and she said well then this place isn't
for you yeah and I'm like what why and
she said because we teach people to be
great and I said no that's cool I mean
I'll be great if you want me to be great
I'll be great so then I got in the union
through doing extra work
and then I ended up within like a year
getting a series and being a series
regular for a year it was called The
Crew so it was sitcom time right right
and I love those days oh isn't it those
were a good day I actually don't love
doing sitcoms I've done a couple and
I don't know my my anxiety and my stress
of like having to learn like Monday you
could do a table read Tuesday Everything
Changes Wednesday you start putting it
on its feet Thursday they're still
making changes and now you're doing it
in front of the networking Studio Friday
you're going up in front of a live
studio audience that is terrifying it's
terrifying now I did it and I thought I
was good at it but I it was too it was
too hard for me stress-wise some people
think it's the easiest job in the world
I don't think that either that's how my
mind works you know and maybe now that
anxiety is a funny thing because I
didn't have it back then me neither
right I mean I did but I was stressed
but now I know what anxiety really is me
too what happened you know it's a funny
thing once it turns on
this happened to me
uh with claustrophobia I'm I'm not too a
little bit Yeah I can't be I hate
elevators oh I could do cave Dives I I
did scuba diving where the where I went
down in tunnels into the Earth for 45
minutes in rock nope the the rock the
tunnels were so small I had to hold my
instruments to my belly because my back
was hitting and my tummy was hitting no
okay Ryan
now I can get I can be on an airplane in
first class and be like oh there it is
uh turn on a movie turn on a movie do
your belly breathing
um hold your Vegas Nerf points what's
your Vegas nerd points so it's in your
neck right yes so it's down behind your
ear on both sides down the neck yeah and
you can put your your finger like this
behind
your ear and kind of wrap your hand
around and then put the other one in the
other armpit
and then do your belly breathing make
sure your exhale is longer than your
inhale
and then you know have Xanax in your
purse because if it's right and then do
drugs and then do drugs but having the
the knowing that I've got that in my
purse then I don't need it
isn't that funny yes because it is it's
a panic and right now I'm doing a course
a big long six month Long training in
this stuff with This brilliant woman
Leslie hutart
um because
I don't want to be caught out like that
again like covid put me under
dude and and anxiety went
to the roof yeah so I have a this is a
six-month course and for for working on
anxiety and yes and there's months that
gives me anxiety yeah that's a lot of
work it's a lot but it's only a few
hours a week because it's actually
something it's called the body wisdom
Academy and it's learning about the
subtle body and how the mind and the
body and the spirit work together so
there it's actually a
grounding
you know all these words we use so much
that none of us know what they mean
anymore but you know it's actually
taking us
out of those traps so you can't really
rush it it's not the kind of thing we
can type a it which type A people get
anxiety these are the people that get
anxiety right we're perfectionists we're
type A we're quick fixes yeah we want to
be in control we want a quick fix we're
going to solve it none of that's going
to work here because we've got to move
back over out of the Mind
because the mind is the the terrorist
and into what you could call the space
of the heart which would be more subtle
um and when we're on a set and on a
plane and getting home and you got to do
laundry into this before I mean you and
I saw each other in a billion planes and
I mean it's just we never stop going
yeah it's a great thing It's a Wonderful
Life
also
there's no room to hear The Whispers
from whatever you think God is
that's that's a
that's a distracted world you know we're
distracted we're moving we're
entertaining we're performing
so you know this course has been I think
where I need to go in the last Act of my
life last act she says like this is the
last it's so funny because someone else
Bruce Campbell yeah he's a good friend
of mine right there signed it hey Rosie
pants my name is coming up a lot right
now in my life he's just a great guy
he's been on the podcast a couple of
times I've gone gotten stone with him
went bike riding I love we were just
texting in fact
you want to see what my last text to
Bruce was yes all right I'll show it to
you it's very quick it's very quick it
is you used to love me I said
he said you used to be lovable
and I go thank you that's the kind of
relationship
that's Bruce Campbell but um but I'm
glad you're doing this and Bruce said
that he's in his third Act and the third
Act is
[ __ ] everything else I'm doing this for
me because this is the third act this is
the final chapter that's it there's
three acts that's it you just do 20 30
then to your 50 55 60 or whatever that's
it and then the rest that's it and so
you're like you're taking care of
anything that you think is a out of
whack yeah imbalanced that's it and that
sort of like what do I want to do
I don't really know you know it's an
interesting question throughout the day
because there's all the stuff I have to
do what do you have to do you gotta pay
property tax and I gotta do the laundry
and I gotta now fix my fence and then I
you know stuff I gotta go to the mailbox
place and get the mail you know you can
have your husband do that I do try to
get him to do as much as possible
Von Stratton he is a Beyond brilliant
musician his music people with anxiety
I mean like that's how I met him because
his music is so brilliant he is an
autistic genius so he's just an autistic
or artistic both okay and so he's not
really good at tasks you know what I
mean he's good at getting the mail great
at getting the mail oh good he can walk
the dogs pretty good
uh
uh good at getting the mail
affectionate
yes and no you know because his type his
Capricorn isn't he he's a Virgo oh okay
they but this autistic artistic
personality
needs a lot of space
because they're always dysregulated
they are born dysregulated
so he they they can't handle inflow that
you know if he goes to the grocery store
he's got to take hours to get back to
Center you know by himself yeah you know
you were talking about
uh I I said was there was there ever a
time when you wanted to quit yeah oh the
same face
what kept you going
um probably not having anything else
that I've ever done to pay my bills
because and and that would probably be
the truth and then when I'm on the set
I was doing a series in 2019 in Canada
in Vancouver which I love Vancouver
series
sacred lies okay and I
was my dog was dying
and I was flying in and out and I was
exhausted
and I actually
uh when they were trying to do the deal
and business Affairs at Facebook Network
were really being dicks
uh and I was in the emergency room with
my dog
and he had a stroke we didn't know what
and my manager called over and over and
over and I finally picked up and was
like
I can't can't talk now that's what the
text meant when I said can't talk now
we've been together for 30 years my
manager and I so so we we can yell at
each other and not hate each other and
he said all right but just hear me out
here's the deal here's what they want we
have an hour and I said well then the
answer is no and I I I've never said no
to anything I can't say no
but it's powerful when you mean it
holding my dog I was like then if they
can't wait
well I'm in the freaking emergency room
goodbye and he took the job for me
anyway and now post pandemic or whatever
now endemic I'm glad he did right but
there was a lot around that job where I
didn't want to be there
but I remember standing there so clearly
waiting to enter the scene the scene was
happening in a bedroom on a set and I
could see a video Village and I could
see the boom guy
and
I was like getting ready to walk in and
do kind of a a great scene great writing
and I was like I
Love Actually I love this I love the set
I love these Kearney [ __ ] a
bunch of crazy bastards just making [ __ ]
it's the best the most creative
I mean the people that such good people
on cruise most crews are always the most
wonderful the best just down-earth real
people I always I'm friends with them I
just feel like I'm a kid from Indiana I
just want to hang out have a smoke with
us right we're like yeah man these are
the best people ever but you love acting
I love acting
that part between action cut now
everything around it right like this we
don't get waiting take after take after
sitting oh my God after sitting after I
mean it's not glamorous people think
I've invited people instead I've talked
about this before and they're like okay
and then like why are you doing this for
the tenth time where do you want to go
tenth time they were so excited you want
to get the hell out and you're like at
10 are you kidding imagine doing it
imagine doing it 12 hours and I'm gonna
do it for another 50 takes you know and
and my feet hurt and uh God knows what
that fog is I've been inhaling for 20
years right I always talk about to be do
we have to have the [ __ ] fog what it
looks really cool yeah it looks really
cool and I'm dead I know and I know they
go it's fine it's fine we did not do one
scene on True Blood without True Blood
definitely with vampires and [ __ ]
always had yeah yeah and we went to
nights every week you know so we flip
back and forth and our shoots
our shoots were minimum we started at 15
Day episodes and we ended up a 25 Day
episodes so we were doing three pages a
day so you're doing that wait a minute
50 25 wait how many what what's it again
say that again we did 25 days for every
20 days for every episode 20 days I'm
small but with all the Supernatural and
all the effects we did 10 days uh-huh
that must have been a fortune to make
that show a fortune and they probably
didn't pay you well a fortune they did
not until we were negotiated you know
when it was a hit and then they were
generous right you know for that two
years who are you close with on True
True Blood Still besides Deborah anwal
you have truest blood the podcast yeah
go listen to that folks you gotta listen
to that it's it's awesome you tell how
much fun you're having but who besides
Deborah are you still really close with
or you could text my vampire crew so
like Moyer Stephen Moyer see I'm gonna
cry there you go you really love the
people you work with who else I love
them so much Anna Paquin are you still
close with her yes that's so beautiful
she seems like a doll she's a doll and
all the people like I got to know like
Sam tramwell I did one scene with him
but I got to know him in the parking
lots and the events and after table
reads and because we really the we were
very segregated I did not not work with
shapeshifters and fairies and all these
other you know inferior Supernaturals
but I got to be friends with like
Michelle Forbes and so I Mariana clavano
like all these people and and and when
I'm doing the podcast and I'm reaching
out to directors and producers and
special effects guys and Camera guys and
and wardrobe people oh my god Audrey
Fisher a wardrobe person
and and her wife Desi I mean like
so the podcast I cry just the whole the
podcast is me crying and Deb keeping
this [ __ ] on the rails
does she always tell you like come on
calm down stop crying she doesn't
outline
really stick close
she'll cry here yes Kristen will cry and
I'll keep going
um wow and you did how many seasons
because you were seven seven the first
season you were recurring and then they
signed the first two first two and then
you became a regular yes and um man
that's great that's great did you love
when they ask you to be a regular I
guess you were tired of becoming a
worker girl I'm not doing this anymore
you have to make me a regular well yes I
said that season one I said that season
two and they were like no
we're good thank you wow so I did a
pilot each year and I was doing a
recurring on another show and I'm
busting my balls like I've been doing
forever flying around and then season
three my manager called me one day and
said it was after table read and he said
what did you do at that table read and
I'm like oh my God I'm gonna be fired
again I've been fired a lot oh I want to
hear this but keep going with the story
okay so I'm like uh nothing I didn't do
I did what I always do I always [ __ ]
bring it to those things because they
fire people yes so and I come from that
comedy world so you [ __ ] bring it you
know skarsgard's so confident with just
in his whole life he's such a calm
wonderful person to to be near to just
absorb some of that skarsgardness but he
just you know eats his lunch and kind of
like oh where are we and then you know
sort of reads his line and and you know
me I'm tap dancing on the tightrope with
the symbols between my knees juggling
plates
so what it feels like so
I said I didn't I did the same thing I
always do I I and he goes what did you
do
my manager he's such a funny guy he's
intense
and I'm like I did the same thing I
brought it Ben I did the same thing he
goes well they want to make you
irregular like
what what wow and then I had done
another pilot and they wanted you and
they we called them and said say can you
release her two weeks early two weeks
early and they said we just sold it no
and I'm like I had to put my head
between my knees they weren't gonna
allow you to do it they weren't gonna
allow me to do it and I called Mark
Gordon big deal producer and he was like
no I called the other producer begged
him and he was just insulted he's like
so you want to do that show but you
don't want to do our show and I'm like
yeah this is a [ __ ] hit it's HBO this
is HBO this is True Blood damn it I mean
Anna won a Golden Globe are you kidding
me I know these people I bet this thing
is going I loved our pilot but let's be
honest we don't know how long it's going
to be on there you could we all just get
off the bus so what happened
oh my God they said no no no HBO is
going we got to close the deal we got to
close the deal they don't know that I'm
on hold
and we called a woman producer there and
I I crying of course begged her
and she said let me see what I can do
and they let me out did the show ever
make it no
I think you know what it and and that's
the interesting thing is that I I've
checked I've checked back on it a couple
of times I was it was like a DC show and
I was playing like the Sarah Palin
character it was pretty fun and but I
think it got aired as like a movie of
the week maybe could you imagine if you
didn't get True Blood and you had to do
that and that was it oh my God and my
life would have been completely
different completely different
these sliding doors where we have no
control which is the anxiety personality
type that doesn't like that
so you know you know usually our types
have had trauma with a little T so
you know we haven't been to Afghanistan
but life has been interesting
that is true yes so before that I'd done
the pilot unhung and got fired
why did you get fired
so
not my fault actually on this one so are
the other ones your fault no actually
none of them were damn it but um I
what's his name he he directed sideways
and he had just won the Oscar um
Alexander Payne thank you thank you Ryan
so he knows things he doesn't know Khan
concentric circles Centric circles he
knows that go ahead yeah that is in your
defense that is more useful to us than
concentric circles it is so why'd you
get fired so so to try to make that
succinct
um this was one of those things and it
just shows the class of HBO actually is
the moral of the end of the story well
uh Sue Nagel she's no longer there I've
never seen a guy picture a show she
didn't take it but anyway go ahead yeah
well I it was one of those auditions
you've probably had these where they say
we've seen everyone in town no one is
right and then you're like okay yeah
exactly boy and there's no problem with
the script of course when they've seen a
thousand actresses who can't make it
work but I do tend to kind of come in
the bottom of the ninth and solve
problems for people
so I did that because they said
actresses just aren't getting the humor
I read the scene and it's a sobbing
divorce scene
and I'm like well
okay so it was set in the midwest thank
God because I gave her a Fargo accent
and I didn't cry
[Music]
so me the crier and so I because then it
was funny
so
and I read with it was the other actor
so it's Alexander Payne and Thomas Jane
Thomas Jane these people that have
interesting names so Thomas Jane reads
with me
and he's a quirky duck right so he's not
like he's kind of improvising which is a
weird thing to do to the person who's
auditioning because I just need to know
what the Rhythm will be and there wasn't
so I get it
fly to Detroit
and we're rehearsing
and Thomas Jane is like he says his line
and then I'm about to say my line and he
says his line again
and then oh
okay and then I go to say my he says
this line again I'm like wait what
what's happening so then he keeps
repeating his line kind of the Stella
Adler thing maybe I'm thinking and then
he kind of starts rolling on the floor
doing yoga or something and I'm like uh
this isn't true I've never
I'm I'm like uh I'm like an old [ __ ]
actress I'm like what do you want you
know all right let's get your pants off
let's get this thing going like I'm
gonna hit my Mark I don't care what you
do right I'm gonna kill this thing I
don't even know that my scene partners
are there because I can't you can't rely
on that you can get fired if you're not
prepared within your own
Circle right and so
I don't really know what's happening so
I do what I did in the test
afterwards
Alexander Payne says
oh my God Thomas you're so great to work
with I would so much rather film what
you just did than what we have to film
oh and Kristen on the day no accent
you'll be crying
and he leaves and he just won the Oscar
and I'm like he's wrong but he just won
an Oscar
so
they had me he said no makeup on Kristen
they dyed my hair mousy they put me in
baggy ugly clothes with food on him and
I'm sobbing for 12 hours snots running
down my face I I don't want to be
married to you
and I'm trying to save this one line
where she's like back in high school you
were the star athlete you were this you
were that and now you're just hung so
there was one line right where I could
maybe still keep my job so then it got
and then the producers would kind of at
the end of the day they went oh good job
Kristen that was very funny
and I'm like wow it's not
it wasn't
and you went home and I went home oh and
I did not get along with the dude Eddie
Eddie James or something he was in the
oceans movies she just didn't get along
he played my husband first person in
ever ever I've never gotten along I get
along with everybody
he hated me and he basically told me
that so yeah he looked me up online and
saw that my dad had guns
and he attacked the [ __ ] out of me about
gun control and I'm like hey I'm a
liberal I got it my dad I loved him he's
dead that was his generation they were
Old West Guns he liked John Wayne okay
so anyway back to the scene right I'm in
tears and I say to him please please can
you let this go we're gonna work
together with playing husband and wife
we're going to be touching each other
tomorrow
bizarre I go back to LA and it's picked
up
and my manager goes aren't you excited
and I'm like uh
I'm confused
and then I was fired they got Anne Heche
she did they rewrote it
and she did a completely different
character and seen and it was so much
better but the night that I got fired I
went out to dinner with my husband and
this woman comes over to me
and she says hi I'm Sue negle I'm the
president of HBO and I'm like oh right
because I only met her in the test
so you're not really able to retain
faces in that circumstance and and she
said it wasn't you
and I'm like how about a classy lady I
didn't see her in the restaurant it
never happens I didn't recognize her she
came up to you that's class and she said
the scene just didn't work you didn't
work with him it's not you and I can
send it to you if you want to see it so
you know it's not you watch it I said
I'm I don't want to watch it oh and at
the end of the day Alexander Payne said
to me you're the best actress I've ever
worked with
and then we called them to say my
manager called him to say well then go
to bat for her it was your direction
that got her fired and he was like hey
I'm out of it I directed The Pilot
I'm good but I couldn't have done True
Blood it all happens for a reason that
one did
it does a lot of these things have
happened to me where I just like I
didn't get that and then all these
things just this didn't get picked up
and then boom yeah I land this yes
oh man so that's a nice one right fired
oh I get True Blood much better
everybody loves me and I love them
you will you always you play a lot of
dark characters yeah and it's funny
hanging out with you here and knowing
you're such like a light you're so fun
you're so easy to talk to you seem you
don't seem like an evil person but then
I watch a movie
like the boy behind the door oh yeah
that was fun and I was like here's
what's funny
I I wasn't I don't know for what reason
but I didn't place it I wasn't I was
watching you but I wasn't it was you
were so good I'm not guys the boy behind
the door it's one of these little
independent movies that's really well
directed yeah she's phenomenal you were
so effed up I so effed up and I had to
look you up who's this like oh it's her
because you were so crazy so crazy and I
was I was just blown away it really gosh
if I was uh if I was directing something
and I was considering some your agent
should send a scene from that or go
watch this movie you can see what she
does she doesn't need to read for you
right that's the kind of movie that was
that performed uh I haven't seen it
because I hate watching myself oh you
another one of those actors who doesn't
like watching themselves have you ever
watched yourself yes
um
well and mainly for the podcast
now I'm having to watch the show like
five times do you like yourself I do you
know I do Pamela I like Pam
you know it really is better watching it
and and I've seen there's another little
movie I did
um the story of Luke was it
um but an autistic kid and I watched
some scenes of that and you see yourself
when you're looping
but
I really love that little movie too
I love playing an evil character so I I
love it right I love it right isn't it
great it's fun it's fun it's more
interesting especially when there's
backstory there's subtext there's yeah
you know and always I always tell people
this that they ask or an actor asks me
it's like it's it's the the easiest
thing to do yeah is just act like you're
bad right and that's never the thing to
do right it's not interesting so true if
you play against it yeah and the lines
are good enough yes it should come
through that's it you shouldn't have to
do too much that's right you shouldn't
have to twirl the mustache right and so
there's stuff where they're like no we
want you to be bad like I was talking
you know we do a talk fill uh podcast
about Smallville Tom and I and Ryan and
I was just talking about one of the
actresses on an episode she was a guest
star but she played it like she was
supposed to be the [ __ ] high school
student yeah she's like I am popular and
this and I'm like oh my God why is she
playing it so on the character uh
caricaturist
characteristic yeah knows yes and you
know it's just like anyway that's yeah
but I love it yes you got to play it
makes it much more interesting and you
know that's the thing with the writing
right and then that you know it's sort
of crazy how true blood came together
where every huge 300 people work to make
that show happen and everyone was
incredible and fabulous and fun and
weird and it comes from the top down
right so all of we'd have 45 speaking
girls every episode and every actor even
background players
were what you just described they just
let the writing play yeah and they were
cast right right so I couldn't play all
the other characters but somehow Pam was
in there and then the writing
collaborates
yeah you know when am I acting
uh professors in college
I was doing what was I doing I was doing
some I was doing check off I was doing
oh wow something and I was in the back
for this long scene it must have been 25
minutes long and I I just go hey Dr
Leonard
um
I don't know what I'm doing here I got
nothing to say right I'm not saying
anything do I need to be here because
Michael
your character has everything to say he
just chooses not to say it ah and I go
huh well
yeah that's sort of like it was a good
nut it was like oh so he's just thinking
listening whatever it is it made me more
interesting yeah instead of just waiting
for my line or waiting for because a lot
of times you're not listening you're
just kind of like oh [ __ ] here I am I'm
in this town you're like did I lock the
front door oh I hope I locked the front
door what are we gonna have for dinner
pizza that's true you know that that's
the perfect description of my husband
actually
because he never talks
well you could talk for him
yeah
by the way you add him I talked for him
I talk around him I talk about him the
role dancing at the blue yeah okay I
mean I haven't seen it but I read that
you had to do you were playing a porn
star yeah and you had to do this nude
scene yeah
now that a lot of actresses or act would
say no I'm not doing that I am not uh
you know I mean we're you know
self-conscious we're all these things it
was brutal we're used very
self-conscious did you not want to do it
did you say no no no no what made you do
it and how did you get comfortable
playing a role like that well that was
intense so I that was in this period
where I was sitcom girl and they were
going extinct and I was not even allowed
to like pre-read for dramas
no one would see me as anything but kind
of the dingbat dung blonde and the funny
girl
and I loved playing those roles and
would have happily done it the rest of
my life but they went away and I had to
eat
so this came along and my manager and I
thought
because he had just won the Oscar for
Postman he did a remake of it I believe
was it Kevin Costner movie no was it
with Jessica Lang did he read what was
the so he had done night he'd adapted
1984. I forget his name and I forget the
the movie
um yeah look up blue iguana
and because he had this crazy reputation
for being one of those directors at that
time and the movie had some Buzz because
it was all improvised no script
so you had Orwell was a novel Orwell's
novel look up dancing at the Blue Iguana
and see who
okay what did he do before that oh he
did do the postman in 1994. yeah was it
yeah Jessica I needed 1984 in 1984 as
well on the nose but um yeah so he
adapted the Orwell's book and it was
brilliant and then he adapted he redid
Postman Always prestigious people here
he was hot at that time right real
prestigious English guy and
so I wanted to and it was improvised
this thing so I wanted to show what I
could do
so you had to improvise your way into
this movie or out of this movie and
depending on what you did or didn't do
you were in it or not in it and so it
was a very weird structure but
um dysfunctional group actually it was
it was not super fun Sandra Oh was in it
Daryl Hannah Sandra Oh and I got to work
together she's so wonderful but I
auditioned so you had to make up a
character
so I made up a character and came in and
a friend of mine helped me
because we knew it was in this triple
world and he was a male stripper
a gay dude one of my best friends and he
helped me make up this character so I
brought this character in and and oh my
God it was in a theater so they had all
the people auditioning just sitting in
the theater watching you watching you it
sucks it sucks I like to be by myself
with nobody I don't want people to hear
me yeah I hate that it's horrible and
you're stuck there for three hours
because each person is going down doing
their thing right then I got a call back
so in our world you do the same thing
you did you don't change your shirt you
don't change nothing because you want to
do what you're doing something right
doing something right so I go back in
with the same character and they're like
what are you doing here with the same
character
and I'm like wow you really want me to
make up another character
like you can just you know like like I'm
on freaking SNL you know what I mean uh
oh I auditioned for that too so anyway I
did make up five characters for that but
oh that was that was an interesting day
wow you gotta love actors we're game man
but back then did they at a certain
point make you take off your shirt to
see if so then because they can't do
that now right no they can't do it now
but they did because then
um Michael called me and said he said
they said all right you know Michael was
there they said all right you'd do the
same character and but I did different
stuff because it's improvised so that's
also awful and terrifying so then he
called and said I want to have lunch
with you so he said look I love you I
want to hire you you're incredible but I
gotta have Daryl Hannah because she puts
butts in seats and she's also incredible
but I had gotten there first but you
know her name came in and then I had to
step aside as you do so then I get a
call that so they've been in rehearsal
for four months improvising in this
crappy theater on Santa Monica months in
a room stripping there's a stripper pole
the whole thing and they call me and say
it's our last day Friday
show up
and bring what you got and we'll see if
you can we can work you into the movie
in a scene or two
I sit there for like five hours in the
hall trying to stay in my head in
whatever character
then they go come on in and the other
girls are all dancing and the music's on
and they're pretending that they're in
the oh God even worse first it was play
improv games
so they all know that improv warm-up
games I've never done improv so to me
this is just
stupid
okay so I do the stupid improv games and
then then we get to well we're in the
the rehearsal room and so it becomes
that I come in and they all hate me and
I'm like okay do they really hate me or
this are we improving okay we're
improving so Daryl Hannah doesn't really
hate me but there was no like hi Kristen
nice to meet you welcome to our Crazy
Crew it was like I walk in the room and
they immediately they were living it
like okay not used to that
um so then I just went all right so then
they go yeah this is Nico she's going to
be headlining so I'm like headlining
okay so I'm the headliner so this whole
thing evolves and then everyone starts
taking their clothes off
in this I'm I'm auditioning so I go [ __ ]
it take my clothes off in the audition
in this this improvisational room yes
you just took your shirt off yes and
your pants yes you got naked naked and
everyone else did yes you're nude and
I'm their nude with everybody how many
people are in the room there's like all
the actresses from the thing like six
actresses the director some other
producers we're all just naked
[ __ ] it I said [ __ ] it and you did it
and you weren't scared I was petrified I
was shaking
and I was like okay this is the film and
I'm I was just being crazy and brave I
guess really more brave because this was
the role and I knew that so and they're
all naked so I'm like all right you know
what you wanna and and they're being Was
Daryl there yeah she was naked naked
what on the pool she was crazy Daryl
Hannah's naked going crazy on a pole
you're naked everybody's naked The
Producers this has to be the best day of
their lives the best day of their lives
and and they might have been in like
perverted lives yes and they might have
been I don't remember who else was like
had on Bottoms or someone had a top on
or whatever but we were all like pretty
much in our skivvies
and then I get a call going you're in
the movie
okay
[Music]
and they go so you're playing a porn
star
and there's going to be an outline so I
get the outline script and it says
no dialogue or anything but it was like
Nico goes on stage to do a striptease
and
it's so incredible no one wants to go on
the stage and follow her
that's and I'm like no pressure
now these girls have been for three
months in stripper School
I I call and go uh what what do I do
that is better than the splits which I
can't do and what I saw Daryl doing on
the poll Sheila Kelly who produced and
starred in the movie started you know
the strippers the exercise thing S curve
or something it's called yeah all around
town these Housewives Are are in LA on
polls doing exercise classes on a
stripper pull that's her her she's made
probably Millions she's so good she's
hanging upside down but you had no class
you had no experience nothing you just
got up there and winged it nothing I
can't even touch my toes I'm not
flexible I mean and I'm like are you
[ __ ] kid what am I supposed to do but
you did it they go well figure it out
so I hire
Michelle Pfeiffer's whip trainer from
Batman
no joke and I go dude teach me a whip
routine because I can't touch my toes I
can't do pull I went to stripper school
for a week and was and hurt my shoulder
I I mean have you seen the scene
yes and did you like it it's so it's so
over the top because here's what
happened after months of working with
the whip guy and I even rehearsed on the
set
I show up
and they've lowered the ceiling all the
lights are hanging down and on the day I
can't do my whip routine because the
whips hits the ceiling because the whip
hits the ceiling so you had to scratch
that I
oh my God if I would have known what a
panic attack was I would have known I
was having one but I could barely
breathe I was like I have nothing then
they bring in all the extras then the
room is lit brighter than an or because
on film it'll look darker
and there's a hundred people there and I
have no routine
and I'm oh and then I had picked the
song Echo and the bunny man yeah but
they couldn't they said we can't play
the song because we're gonna have to put
it in later in post
and I'm like
uh oh my God I can't do this
and
I tried I did one with the whip the Whip
trainer goes I'll give you a shorter
whip you can totally do it you can
totally do it I did one or so swing
trying to keep it low and it got caught
in the lights
and I'm standing there half dress going
I'm sorry I have to start over hello
hello
but you did it so I just took all my
clothes off so the deal was that I had
to show boobs and not Bush I just took
everything off because I had to fill
three minutes of song and I had no whip
oh my God and the first take was so bad
my friend the male stripper was there
and the day to help me he came over and
he was like
you are tanking
you're not going to be in this movie you
have to freaking own it and he was like
gave me like you know like a slap
something you'd see on some reality TV
show and I'm like uh-huh and he's
shaking me and he's like you got this
I'm like I don't you do I do you you do
I do and then I they just I went out
there and I just [ __ ] took everything
off and went nuts and they clapped yes
they were paid to but they should have
clapped because this is like and I had
been working out and not eating much
I've been eating salads and working out
and spray tanning I was so nervous
oh my God that sounds like a panic
attack if I've never heard one
that is insane and then the the one
acting scene I got
Radford was in a mood and I start the
scene sleeping and
um
and they go action and I open my eyes he
goes cut I can see you acting and I'm
like what I just opened my eye I can see
you're acting he's yelling at me I'm
like okay sorry I do it again
I open my eyes I sit up he goes no no no
no no no you've got to be it
try again
I'm like wow and they looked at me and
went welcome
so this went for 17 takes 17 days and
then he comes out and goes forget it get
off my set
leave goodbye
I think
I I'm I'm in the parking lot all the
cast met me with champagne they were
like it's not you
but they didn't cut that scene then he
calls me from the editing Bay
and he says you know it's Michael I'm
like yes what and he goes
you're brilliant
it's my favorite scene in the movie
something like that and he said which
take do you think I used and I'm like I
don't want to play this game
the the 11th I don't know the first yep
he's the first so God love him he called
me and he told me that he used the first
take and I was brilliant so his way is
to like scare you this is called [ __ ]
talking with Kristen Bauer is it Kristen
Bauer Von Stratton it it you know I just
say do you want when we do the show
she's gonna be just Kristen Bauer yeah
it's easier okay [ __ ] talking with
Kristen Bauer these are my top tier
patrons who get to ask these questions
uh they also get shout outs and other
things go to patreon.com inside of you
to join and support the podcast could
use your help here we go this is fast
rapid fire okay Kelly s love your acting
what inspires you
um thank you
I the writing inspires me and working
with other people
that inspire you yeah Maya P what is
something people would be surprised to
learn about you
I love John Wayne really I'm obsessed
with John Wayne yeah yeah
Christy wow what was Anna Paquin like to
work with and can you get her on inside
of you oh she's the best the best the
best would she do the podcast I'll ask
her when I when she says yes you can
tell her what fun you had right yes
you know she is absolutely the most
incredible actress the most professional
the most Brave talk about naked outside
at night and 19 degrees never complains
and has your back
uh I remember when she won the Oscar for
a supporting actor for the piano yeah I
remember as a little girl watching her
as she was a little girl she said I just
want to thank beanie and I wanted and
she had this cute new and it was so
adorable and I was like oh I love this
girl the little New Zealander yeah
Michelle K did you get to keep your
fangs or anything cool from True Blood I
did keep my fangs and we were gonna have
a Fang off on the podcast because I
still lisp and Deb doesn't and I broke
them so I have to try to fix them I have
to Gorilla Glue them you can fix them I
hope so little Lisa what was the last TV
show you binge watched Ted lasso really
mm-hmm
Raj did you have a mentor that helped
guide you as you tried to pursue an
acting career my acting teachers
um Jocelyn Jones Jeffrey Tambor and
Milton casales
who do you remember growing up that was
a huge influence on who the woman that
you've become
who who really inspired you who was who
was it that gave you confidence that
gave you love unconditional love and
gave you that confidence well the tears
you can see probably my dad really was
he always the one that said I love you
I'm so proud of you yeah I'll do uh
whatever you do I'm happy with I just
want you to be happy he was there was a
phase there where it was like but go to
college and get a degree and if you
don't I'm gonna hate you forever
um because you're a loser so there was
that phase but then he came around and
said I can't believe I didn't trust you
oh
that's beautiful I know you could just
be an honest person an honest father
yeah you know just admit your flaws
admit when you're wrong be a human being
yeah that's something I just never
experienced never yeah and I'm sorry you
didn't because life is hard enough as it
is if your parents don't believe in you
right
it's rough see that's that's trauma with
a little that's a trauma with a medium
tea you know that's dysregulation from
the start which I for other reasons have
dysregulation from the start because
there was a big loss in my family when I
was a kid but what was that loss you
know how to talk about it a sister who
died how young seven do you remember no
I was I was basically in the womb when
it happened and and um was born into a
family that was trying to move forward I
I I just hear
everyone always says the worst thing
imagine was losing a child it's the
worst it's the worst I can't even
imagine yeah my poor mom yeah what's
what's next besides you're doing your
art where can people go see your art
so my website is being redone because I
think if you go to Kristen Bauer art
it's literally a porn site comes up
someone perfect guys had to yeah exactly
go to christianbauer.com and look at my
art there and then I'm and see what
happens because either way it's gonna be
fun but I go to your Instagram and now
you can I'm sure you could find stuff
exactly my Instagram which is Kristen
Bauer I I post my paintings that I'm
doing now and I'm doing the podcast and
I'm auditioning this blood and you're
auditioning yeah what do you want to do
do you want to do a comedy next a movie
uh do you is this really just anything
that's good writing
I kind of want to do I'd love it to be
good writing but my top priority is
decent hours
you say that I don't know what happened
but once I hit 50 I'm like I I don't
want to work every day 14 hours a day I
don't want to do it I don't want to do
it I just want to work a couple days and
have my ding up my dog and my friends me
too and do fun things I want to hang out
with my dog and my friends yeah I don't
want to do that that's everybody's goal
no one wants to work all the time I'm
over 50. I don't want to work 14 hours a
day plus commute minimum
I don't want to be outside all night
listen to this woman I don't want to be
cold or too hot I don't
you know this this has been awesome I I
really can talk to you forever I could
talk to you forever this is really fun
Ryan wasn't this great it's so fun it
really was great we went over what is
this 10 minutes over probably I never go
10 minutes you don't very seldom
probably 20 of the time wow I go over an
hour 55 minutes an hour sometimes it's
but yeah I I could go on but we could do
this is great where do you live by the
way not your address but where what part
of town North Hollywood well you're
right around the corner this wasn't hard
for you no it wasn't all right this I
love you for coming and uh thank you for
allowing me the inside of you today
thank you for allowing me to be inside
of you today that's inside of you
podcast as you know guys follow Kristen
Bauer she's amazing if you haven't seen
her work see the boy behind the door see
True Blood see uh uh Once Upon a Time
see
um
what else should they say well fun fact
I was Man Hands on Seinfeld that's right
yeah there's a fun fact they used one of
the crew guys hands for the insert yes
yes how much popularity did you get for
that well a popularity and more
residuals than I got from HBO like how
much have you made off being on one
episode of Seinfeld as man hands oh my
God I wish I knew that because would you
say more than twenty thousand dollars
yeah I'm guessing off a guest star off a
guest star
oh for guest star that paid me probably
3 000 on the day do you know anybody
shout at you man well yes and it is
really fun the fun part is once a decade
I will randomly see Jerry Seinfeld at
the grocery store or something right so
it's so Random how are you well yeah and
then I think oh he's not gonna remember
you know a billion guest stars and then
I go he won't know my name so then I go
should I say I should I and then I
usually walk over to him and go
I am man hands it's so fun oh yeah
immediately immediately he's so friendly
and lovely
how funny is that oh okay of course I
remember you yeah yeah he does
that's amazing you know I'm one of the
few people I haven't seen that episode
but I'm going to I've only seen probably
10 episodes of Seinfeld yeah I hadn't
seen it either but my brother is
obsessed and most of the world is but I
want to sit down and just watch every
season I started doing that during the
pandemic because I needed to laugh I
watched cheers that I hadn't seen I
watched Seinfeld so brilliant I mean
cheers is brilliant yeah last last
question favorite and Ryan I'm going to
ask you this favorite theme song from
the 80s
or 90s TV shows
I'm trying to just don't say friends
what was I haven't seen friends
um
we were opposite them but we've been
together for a million years I'll say
Magnum Magnum how did it go
um
I don't remember I can't remember I
can't do it I know I could hear it
though
Magnum
it's also a condom
yeah that's right though that reminder
is it Magnum PI yeah look the the
original with Tom Selleck so I watched
that whole show through during the
pandemic
so the reason I don't know it's the best
theme song but I do
have happy memories because I love the
show I love the show I love Tom Selleck
what about you Ryan
I hadn't I don't know any 80s television
or 90s what about 70s
because they're all in the family uh
I've been watching 70s shows
Rockford Files I've been Mash I can
think of mash mashed oh I've been
watching MASH a bit
when the last track started
oh that's a great it always makes me cry
for some reason I know it's when I hear
that song and the helicopter coming down
I just think of my childhood and
thinking I think of my grandma's house
or something Family Ties always really
liked cheers is a great one cheers is a
great one on the piano Golden Girls
um ah you remember Golden Girls yeah but
I haven't seen it really and by the way
listen to this one
You're gonna laugh at me probably never
heard of this show have you ever heard
of um give me a break
Nell Carter really she sings the theme
song it's the one from the very first
season I believe when she goes give me a
break cause I shall meet one give me a
break yeah yeah all right I love you
thanks for being here
all right I hope you enjoyed that I
enjoyed that good yeah I enjoy it I
enjoy
podcasts I enjoy my guests especially
when they
when they open open up like that
um I mean yeah that's the audition story
as well man that is the craziest story
ever it's just she just gets naked
doesn't care so let's go let's go but
yeah just the the pressure
yeah just like and women deal with way
more pressure than we deal with way more
yeah hopefully things are turning around
I think they're turning around a little
bit so you know yeah but uh good Lord
women have to go through jeez uh thanks
for listening to the podcast today uh
we're about to do our shout outs to all
the top tier
um
patrons patrons who really support this
show and keep it going uh your support
is so important and I appreciate it go
to patreon.com inside you remember this
the new CD is out go to sunspin.com get
your album shirt mug calendar
um I'm really excited about it I think
you're going to really dig the merch
you're going to dig the album and also
uh the cons we will be I'll be in San
Francisco this coming weekend Friday
night Smallville nights with Tom Welling
Saturday and Sunday signing the
following weekend in Columbus I think
it's Galaxy con Columbus uh for uh
Saturday and Sunday Saturday Smallville
nights and the following weekend which
is like the 11th or something Pittsburgh
uh
I'm really excited about Pittsburgh too
The Dawn of the Dead mall where they
shut down and the dead is right across
the street oh cool yeah I'm a dumb nerd
John heater will be there you know house
will be there Paula duel
s The Griswolds
like Chevy Chase and killer and Beverly
D'Angelo and uh what's what's the uh the
girl who is riding in the red car
from
vacation yeah from Christmas Vacation
oh no from vacation yeah the hot one
who's he's always looking at slapping
the bread together
she'll be there so you can get pictures
in the car with them but come see me of
course too get pictures with me and Tom
and and the crew uh I believe Kristen
crook might even be there so look on our
Instagrams Twitter's look online
um but thank you for all the support
make sure you subscribe write a review
uh here are the top tiers couldn't do it
with Adam here we go Nancy D Leah s
Sarah V little Lisa Yukiko Jill e Bryan
H Nico P Robert B Jason W Sophie and Raj
C Joshua D Jennifer and Stacy L Jamal F
Janelle B Kimberly e Mike
e l Don Supremo 99 more Santiago M Chad
W Lee n p Janine R Maya P Maddie s
Belinda and correct Chris H Dave a
Sheila G Brad d Ray H tab of the T Tom
and Liliana a Talia M Betsy D Chad d b b
Dan and big Stevie W Angel M Rhiannon C
Corey
Michelle a Jeremy C gav inator correct
David C John B Brandi D Camille s Joey M
Eugene and Leah Nikki G Corey Patricia
Heather L Jake B making T Mel s Orlando
C yes Caroline
are yes Christine
s yes Sarah yes yes Eric a chain R Emma
are correct Andrew M zoduichi
77 76 Oracle Karina and Amanda are
Amanda s gen B Kevin e Stephanie K Lena
82
Jarrell Billy s uh you guys listening I
I'm just I'm telling you uh you know I
hope you stick around as a patron if
you're enjoying the podcast you stick
around on patreon uh because uh we want
to continue to do the show I Guess
That's it man what a great episode uh we
have a really great episode coming up
next week so don't miss it the holidays
are coming make sure you listen to talk
Ville you can hear me and Ryan and Tom
Welling and our opinions about the show
we're wrapping up the first season uh
soon it's uh the episodes are really fun
and I hope you're listening to that and
you're subscribed and you write reviews
for all that stuff too I love your
support I love I appreciate you thanks
for uh all the love and Ryan good to see
you good to see you too from the
Hollywood Hills in California I'm
Michael rosenbaugh and I'm Ryan Taylor
goodbye everybody see you guys hey make
sure you're good to yourself that's the
most important thing be good to yourself
I'll see you
foreign
[Music]